Tout est sous contrôle.
On a géré la situation comme des adultes.
Mon pire ennemi est en train de faire un bûcher pour ma petite pomme.
Mais mon fidèle mestre, Yorel...
M'a confectionné une potion anti-feu.
Qui me permettra de me jeter dans les flammes.
Sans ressentir la moindre douleur.
Belyr ?
On a un problème.
J'en étais sûr.
Bon alors, j'ai une bonne...
Et une mauvaise nouvelle.
Ok, commence par la mauvaise.
La mauvaise nouvelle, c'est qu'on va devoir te déguiser en vieille dame.
Quoi ?
Mais je comprends rien...
C'est quoi la bonne nouvelle ?
Je t'ai dit bonne nouvelle ?
Pardon, je suis fatigué.
Y a pas de bonne nouvelle.
Y a une mauvaise et une horrible.
Horrible nouvelle.
C'est quoi la horrible, horrible nouvelle ?
Y a plus de potion.
Quoi ?
Je me suis endormi pendant la cuisson.
Et bah c'est pas grave ! Je le prends quand même !
Fabriquer un potion anti-feu avec du scrilax trop cuit ?
Non mais sérieusement...
Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
Non mais c'est pas ça.
C'est que c'est hyper précis.
Ça perd ses propriétés quand c'est trop cuit.
Mais je m'en fous moi ! J'ai plus rien à perdre !
Ah non mais j'ai renversé le chaudron aussi.
Putain Yorel...
Je te hais ! Je te hais !
Mais moi aussi, je me hais !
Ouais, mais j'ai un plan ! Ah !
Ça y est, je m'en rappelle !
J'ai créé une potion magique...
Qui te permettra de simuler ta mort.
Pendant 1h.
L'idée m'est venu, comme ça.
En écrivant une nouvelle, sur une histoire folle !
Entre une jeune femme et une jeune homme...
Qui décident de s'enfuir pour vivre leur amour au grand jour !
Malgré la rivalité des deux clans qui les séparent...
- Yorel.
Ouais ?
Ta mère.
Ta mère ! Enchaîne !
Ok.
Si tu affrontes Aelys dans cet état là, tu es foutu.
Ta seule chance, c'est de simuler ta mort.
Et fuir le Royaume.
Viens, on s'enfuit ensemble.
Fais moi confiance.
Avec la potion ça va marcher.
Et maintenant...
Que le duel au bûcher, commence !
Je trouve ça, à la fois très stupide et courageux de ta part.
Mais je peux pas cacher mon excitation à l'idée de ce duel.
Très bien, fille de dragon.
Mais d'abord...
Laisse moi boire ma potion de courage.
Le pleutre !
OH MON DIEU !
Ce n'était pas de la potion !
Mais du poison !
Belyr va quitter la Terre !
Il va pas s'enfuir, olala, non !
Il va mourir, olalalala...
Bon.
Attends, au pire je lui couperai la tête quand il sera mort.
Vous êtes tous témoins de ce qu'y vient de se passer, hein ?
Ouais.
Il a essayé de ma frapper avec la force d'un enfant !
Il a voulu me griffer là, comme un petit chaton.
Je serais donc en droit de le tuer.
Devant vous !
Mais...
Je suis un bon roi.
Je suis un bon roi !
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Appelle-moi, roi dragon.
Et tu vivras.
Je vais prendre la mort.
Ah bah non.
Ouais, ouais, c'est vrai. Vas-y tape là.
Bon ok.
Tu sais quoi Belyr ?
Tu me déçoit.
Je renonce à te tuer.
Tue-le pour moi.
Hyper classe cette phrase, mon seigneur.
Et là, surgissant de par-delà les arbres.
Un homme...
Magnifique.
Sur son cheval majestueux.
Cet homme...
C'était Clarisse.
Tu m'as vendu, fils de chien.
C'est vrai.
3000 pièces.
1500 et des bottes.
Alors moi je me suis dit...
Elle va nous ramener du pain.
Non ! Elle sort une épée !
D'accord !
Pour couper du jambon ?
Et bien non !
Pour défier Aelys !
Waow.
Alors ?
Qui est-ce qui va déflorer la pucelle ?
Et saluez !
Ouais !
Ah il s'est fait battre par une fille !
Clarisse ! Clarisse ! Clarisse ! Clarisse !
Je suis passé par beaucoup d'étapes dans ma vie.
J'ai été opprimé.
On m'a jeté en prison.
Je suis tombé dans la drogue.
On m'a même piqué ma copine.
Mais à force de courage et d'amitié.
Tout est bien qui fini bien.
Personne n'est mort, à part des paysans.
Bon, va quand même falloir changer la déco mais...
L'essentiel est là.
J'ai récupéré mon trône.
Belyr ?
Faut qu'on parle.
Ah les femmes !
On les aime, hein.
Mais quand elle vous vol le trône...